[Music]
so basically i i'm we were facebook
friends now so we talk a little bit
there but i first met you at hustle con
i think this event that i hosted in 2019
and you're one of the best people we've
ever had we've had hundreds of people
and i'll
i'll tell you why two things the first
i think you spoke right when so this is
max he started grammarly we'll do an
intro in a second but i think you spoke
when
you guys had just raised maybe a hundred
million dollars at a billion dollar
valuation or something like that is that
right
yeah that was uh yeah that was uh 120 uh
and
i we didn't disclose validation at the
time yeah but if i had to get yeah you
didn't uh but i think i heard rumors and
like i just i'm guessing it was like in
that range and it didn't matter but yeah
but basically um
i made a comment to you i'm like that's
pretty cool right and you
you kind of replied back you weren't
cocky but you were very confident and
still humble but you kind of had a grin
and i forget exactly what you said but
it was something like yeah it's gonna
get much bigger too and i i loved that
like subtle confidence and then at the
event what you talked about i don't even
remember the title but the idea was
basically like you're an engineer but
you've done a really good job of like
evolving past just engineering and you
like said this is how like i engineer
like good products and this is like
everything you looked at was from an
engineer like uh about reverse
engineering different stuff and i
thought that was incredibly fascinating
do you remember what i'm talking about
oh yeah i do i remember that i actually
use it mantra a lot in inside the
company as well when we look at
different markets and where to go next
and it's just a universally good
framework that uh uh works for many
things yeah just kind of looking at
things narrowly identifying the sweet
spot and then just going broader from
there this is max litvin lit vin he
started this company called grammarly
before grammarly you had another company
called like blackboard i think right
that was not my company that was a
company that bought my company so my
company was my dropbox
not to be confused with dropbox it was a
plagiarism detection company and it was
bought by blackboard in 2007
um and then they spent two years with
blackboard uh kind of a part burnout
part just being
been there and that was like a a a
compared to grammarly a mild success
right like it was it was financially
good but it wasn't like this huge huge
multi-billion dollar company oh yeah
that was uh that was uh just a start it
could have grown big
but
education is was at the point a
relatively difficult market to to be in
and wasn't as big of a market uh plus
our product was fairly narrow it was
just doing one thing
for one group of people
so we kind of saw that
it can grow to this point but further
it's going to be very slow and very
difficult so that's why we decided to
sell plus we had bigger ideas and you
started grammarly and at this point can
you reveal can you reveal how big it is
because i i like it's shockingly large
yeah so we raised that
13 billion valuation and we disclose
that valuation i still think it's a
conservative it's conservative one why
because
grammarly is a very non-standard company
and very non-standard product
it's easy to see it for less when it is
um and
and that
that's kind of reflected often in in in
perceptions of of everyone if investors
of uh
sometimes even potential team members we
have to explain why it's big and you
know but uh
that also helps with the last
competition well and like
and by the way you guys bootstrapped it
for a long time so like you and your
co-founder like it's not like you own
like four percent of this company you
guys probably you own like a very
substantial amount so like
actually so
you're on paper you're you're probably a
multi-billionaire at this point uh it
depends on whom you believe uh there is
some information that's not fully
accurate
uh
but yeah we we managed to
keep significant portion of the company
with the founders and employees uh
employees only actually quite a lot did
um
when i heard about grammarly the reason
why i wanted you to come on to the
podcast and at hustlecon is because i
think
my reaction is the same reaction most
people in business had which is like a
this is just a chrome plug-in b this is
just spell check like there's no way
that either of those things are
interesting and then i learned about it
and i was like oh this is like way
bigger than
it just looks like that it's way more
than that did most people
or like there's
most people dismissive of like it just
being a chrome plug-in
some people are dismissive uh quite a
lot and uh i wouldn't say dismissive
it's not like completely oh there's
nothing uh
but uh underestimate the impact and the
importance of it
and that's that's an interesting uh
conversation always always very similar
because um they kind of think oh this is
a good product this is a cool product
but not for me because well i know what
i'm doing
and then
they try it and it helps it helps the
material ways and
especially when you measure results
because you know when you don't measure
things and then just you know typing
away uh it saves you from an
embarrassment or helps you phrase
something more clearly kind of yeah
that's cool but
what's the impact of that
show me the money
but when it's done on the business scale
uh and it's measured and it's uh kind of
assessed uh you can see like percentages
improvements in in different metrics
productivity satisfaction and so on and
that ends up is updated we bought it at
the hustle so i i had it for uh the
whole company
um i don't remember what it what it cost
but i remember seeing the bill every
month hundreds of dollars a month and
everyone loved it and i loved it i i
still use it so like i totally
i totally buy i i totally once i started
using it i was like oh my god i get it
but
one thing that i've always been
fascinated with is is
just plugins as a business um
particularly two types of plugins
wordpress plugins
um there's a bunch of guys that have
like some substantially sized
substantial size businesses selling
wordpress plugins you know like 25 50
million dollars a year and then chrome
plugins which do you i don't know if you
like describe yourself as a chrome
plug-in as a business i i don't think
you are but like
it's definitely like the one of the main
ways in which most people interact with
you right
uh for now yes uh we
just recently
switched over to our flagship product
being uh operating system level
integration so it works similarly to
chrome plug-in except it integrates with
all the apps not just web apps
uh so that's uh that was a big
switchover that happened uh
in
december so just a lot of months ago
so that's uh that expands the surface
area for grammarly now it's in
microsoft powerpoint and uh you know
oracle applications and wherever
wherever you want
um did you uh why did you hire a ceo
when did you do that
that's kind of jumping topics but uh
yeah we um we brought in a ceo i think
in 2011
uh and um
one reason one big reason for that was
that
um
both uh alex michael founder and i we
have a philosophy that everybody should
be doing should be in their zone or
genius doing what they like and what
what they're good at
and
nobody no one of us was really
experienced or
or even that passionate about scaling
organizations
uh and that's what we're kind of the
biggest thing we were looking for from
as uh from uh ceo uh
teaching us and and
doing that basically scaling the company
because we realize that to do what we
need to do we need a lot of people we
need a big company it's a
kind of a number of people and size is
not a kind of a
desired outcome in itself it is a
necessity because the goals are so big
that you can't do it with uh 20 people
or 30. how many employees did you have
when you hired brad
uh
i think 20 something oh wow
nothing i mean small
small
yeah we were fairly small uh
we were we were
uh
making good revenue and being profitable
at the time already uh but the company
was still very small um and that's
that's kind of a
that that realization we need to their
opportunities big and we need to scale
uh that pushed us to look for kind of
external expertise how did you
because
at that point
you i guess you didn't raise money so
you and your partner like oh it was like
your business it was your company and
like your money how did you
how did you not micromanage brad um
because i did the same thing and
not micromanaging is tough because
you're like oh my god if you make a
mistake you're gonna lose money and
that's like my money and so it's like
really stressful to like let someone
fail sometimes and learn
were you micromanaging or were you
pretty emotionally healthy about it
i'd like to think we were emotionally
healthy maybe brad would disagree i
don't know i wish he i actually will ask
him but um
i think part of it was out of necessity
there was just so much to do that if
you're micromanaged you get stuck you
don't not make progress so there was
just no time or resources or energy to
micromanage anybody
we had to divide and conquer to to
actually keep making progress
because so that's a lot of work so just
just from the volume of things to do
everybody had to do their own thing so
that that happened naturally and part of
it is a philosophy that again alex and i
share that
basically if you bring in
smart people on board
like not listening to them or not
letting them think independently is a
waste basically
there is no point in bringing smart
people on board uh so that's uh that's
that made it easy to
kind of uh give freedom and give space
to to brad and other um
leadership team members what were your
goals early on like
when you started the business we're like
man i think this can make 10 million
dollars a year and provide a good
lifestyle or like i think this could or
was it like i think this could be like a
multi-billion dollar thing like what
were your goals early on um
i think we decided that it could be a
multi-billion dollar business
during our conversations with brad
partially uh so kind of alex and i we we
hoped it could be but then once we
started talking with brad about
valuation plans and all that um when he
was thinking about joining then it
become pretty clear that yes there is a
multi-billion dollar market out there uh
are we gonna capture it or not
to be just to be determined but um at
that point but uh
there is definitely an opportunity so
the size of the opportunity became clear
fairly early um but
past there that that took years what was
the vision
that made or what what did you see that
made you feel that it could be a
multi-billion dollar opportunity and
what was the vision and were there any
was there any numbers that you saw
early on that which said like oh my gosh
there's something here
yeah so
i think the breakthrough moment was when
we saw that it is possible to help not
just professional writers people who
write for living every day but also help
casual writers or people who write as
part of their job but or part of their
life but not like a key part so writing
is not their like main product they're
no you know like novelists or or
researchers who are published and so on
so when we saw that it's possible to
make a product that's useful for
everybody else uh then it clicked
uh
a very simple formula if you look at
amount of time we spent communicating
and creating knowledge uh as a humanity
as all people in the world that is a
huge percentage of our time and it's
increasing because we spend less time
doing things with our hands
manufacturing is being automated it's
not like we're doing it manually anymore
as much
so if you take this time that we spend
communicating and creating knowledge and
make it even one percent more effective
the impact is in
trillions not not even billions uh so
can we do something that makes
communication one percent more effective
on average for everybody that doesn't
sound impossible that sounds like
something is doable uh that's doable so
so we decided i had that aim same
insight except i
did it in such a horrible worst way so
basically um i learned how to be a
copywriter so like i read books on
copywriting and like on persuasive
writing and my theory was like oh my
gosh like with texting or like online
dating i i was single at the time in 21
so it was all about like dating i'm like
oh man if i were to learn how to write
better in my messages to girls who i
match with like my life is going to be
better and then i was like
wait a minute if i learn how to write
better i could sell more stuff if i
learn how to write better i can make
people feel emotions about like this
cause that i want them i'm like just
writing better like
it changes it makes it life more
practical but also
it
uh makes you think better so like if you
can if you have an idea for something
and you're forced to write it out you'll
see all the holes in idea and you'll and
you'll force yourself to like lay it out
and so i was like oh i'll teach people
how to write better and so i created a
course on how to write better of course
like obviously creating a software
product it was out of my league but like
that was clearly the better move to do
but the same insight was like
everything that we do is via a text
whether it's a text message or an email
or a website
and even if it's via like the spoken
word
i have to write that anyway so like
writing is like the most important thing
that you can master i just wish i would
have approached it in a software way as
opposed to just selling a 300 course
yeah software is more scalable that's
that's true and
uh and actually what you said about
writing uh it also applies to speech
we when we do user research we notice
that um
people who use grammarly repeatedly
adopt patterns of communication more
effective patterns of communication
translated to uh non-written
communication as well so for example if
grammarly keeps suggesting that you
don't use kind of a wordy or wig or weak
sentence structures you stop or reduce
use of them in speech as well so i so
kind of good habits rub off and and
translate to other modes of
communication so here's my opinion so
have you ever heard of copywork
all right so in like the um
1700s 1800s
and up until like 1910
one of the ways in america that we would
teach children how to write well it's
the same way that we would teach them
how to play an instrument so if i wanted
to teach you how to play the piano i'm
not gonna say like go ahead like write
go write a piano song i would say well
let's play jingle bells let's learn how
to play happy birthday then after that
we can move to like some more pop songs
that you really like and then you do
that for like two years
and you like see patterns and you like
understand you just copy other people's
music and in doing that you see patterns
and then eventually you're like oh i
know the rules to the game now now i can
decide to follow them to break them but
i can make my own
and it's the same thing with writing
but we don't do that and so what that
means is i think one of the easiest ways
to learn is you find great writing that
you really like and you just literally
copy it by hand
and in doing that you like see the
patterns and that's called copy work
it's not a very popular way to learn how
to write now but in my opinion it's one
of the most powerful i would say
grammarly in a sense it's doing that
because in real time you're learning but
it's far better than just saying like go
and write like just like spend a lot of
time writing your own stuff i think
copying other people is far better
um
anyway it's something i've been playing
with i'm i'm
not a lot of people have heard of
copywork i thought maybe you would have
but uh
it's like not very well known
no i haven't heard of it but i've seen
it done in many many fields
like uh
at one point i i was passionate about
photography and same there you just
basically try different uh try to
basically copy different photographs and
recreate them and then this way you
learn the language of that art uh
so so yeah that applies to many many
areas
how technical were you and your
co-founder were you technical enough to
build the first handful of iterations
um
so i was very technical um so for
example the previous
plagiarism detection company
i wrote
the core uh the core algorithm and and
uh most of the code originally most of
the kind of back end code not the front
end um
but
when we were
working on grammarly
i don't think i did any production code
i coded some of the like experiments
landing pages payment checkout process
like some stuff
something you don't even need to code
anymore today if you didn't want to
yeah yeah yeah yeah so i coded some of
that but i didn't code the like uh like
a real production grade stuff mostly
because i'm i'm not a formerly a
software engineer i'm a kind of a
self-trained coder but kind of building
a real complex software is not my thing
plus i had to i had to manage the
business full time so
when we started out
i was responsible for
finance marketing
like pretty much
like
lots lots of things like basically
everybody has to wear a lot of hats in a
small company so the running of the
business occupied pretty much my whole
time so
it was no time for so you just hired you
did you guys just self-fund it and hire
a couple people to help build the first
version
uh
we hired quite a num quite a significant
number of people uh we also had a
technical co-founder on board
um a
demo leader
who helped build out the technical team
uh so he was responsible for um
for the technical side initially uh but
yeah because of our previous exit we had
some savings that we could put into
grammarly and some substantial savings
we could put into grammarly so basically
we were both founders and the first
investors how much did you spend to get
the to make it work until like it was a
sellable product
uh
i don't remember but it was quite like a
million or 10 million 500 000 do you
remember
uh
i think it was close to a million um but
it was a product that worked only for
very small audience very very small use
case and it was not real time so
basically what happened was
you
write a book a chapter of a book because
it couldn't check the whole book at once
or you write a research paper you submit
it to
[Music]
the initial like the old grammarly
and then you go make a cup of coffee and
then you drink the cup of coffee and
then you wait a little bit more and then
it spits out the result
and the result was probably half of it
was real issues and half of it was false
positives
but at the time the audience the the
target market was fine with that because
if you spend like two months writing a
book
like what's extra half an hour to review
all the potential issues right even if
they're not real but that wouldn't fly
with uh with business writers for
example if you're writing a business
email that you need to send in 20
seconds you're not going to deal with
false positives and did that version get
you to profitability
yeah oh what'd you charge for 100 a
year
uh
we charged i think 90 dollars a year
something like that uh yeah um
yeah or hundreds so yeah i think 995
dollars a year how did the people hear
about it the first users
uh
so that was interesting because we
launched two
parallel streams one to consumers and
one to
uh businesses educational institutions
publishers
basic companies consulting companies and
um
the consumer channel took off like it
grew exponentially from basically week
one uh in enterprise or b2b um
it took a longer to build so
once we
kind of pushed both of them in parallel
for about half a year
uh we saw that well
kind of makes sense to focus on consumer
for now because it's just growing like
wildfire uh but uh
b2b requires much more pushing much more
hiring more people intensive because you
need sales team and all that so we kind
of decided to
slow roll it a little bit um
and focus on consumer for first few
years and deal with it through paid
marketing or organic
uh we did everything um
we we tried uh all the channels
available to us and uh obviously
different channels have different
benefits um
at the time
social was also easier to to get free
promotion from uh right now obviously
kind of facebook and others just want to
capture all the value they create
but back then uh it was easy to it gets
easier to get stuff viral on social and
just get like free promotion from that
um seo was easier as well
uh so many things were just like many
channels were uh quite easier to do uh
but we relied on paid uh early on quite
a bit uh because it's uh
it's a very quick feedback
uh
you design an ad
you send it uh or kind of put it in the
system and then you get back results
like within hours
and it tells you if the message
resonates if there is a market for that
if you're finding that market correctly
you know that within like hours uh it's
in in more traditional world it's a
weeks of hundreds of thousands of
dollars
yeah so that's uh that was uh that was
kind of why we were so
uh bullish on paid from early on even
though it costs a lot of money
what companies are you guys trying to
buy companies
um
not
specifically i mean we're open to that
uh but we're not like hunting to buy
companies is there a problem
that you need to be solved and you saw
that this other company was solving that
problem that you'd buy it
so like let me give you an example the
uh the founder of jet
you know jet.com
they sold the walmart for some billions
of dollars and he's like man if walmart
if we could figure out a way how to
reduce returns by helping people pick
the right sizes we would buy that
company for a lot of money
is there anything
inside of grammarly we're like man we
haven't figured out blank yet but if
someone did figure out blank that's a
cool company we would buy that's a cool
problem solved that we would buy
uh yeah there are many things um like
things around
um
doing more on device uh like doing more
and more processing on device i think
that that would be very interesting to
us because
um
it didn't it enables uh
better user experience lower lag
potentially higher performance um
it also helps alleviate some potential
privacy concerns so kind of a uh a
no-brainer to do more stuff on device
and it's cheaper for for for us to sorry
what does that mean you mean
like instead of you paying for all this
cloud space for everything for the the
for yeah
yeah calculating the suggestions on
device so basically whenever uh we say
oh this needs to be shorter or we
rephrase it like that making that
determination on your phone or on your
laptop rather than sending it to cloud
and and having our servers crunch
numbers so that's uh that's kind of a
that that that has number of benefits
for uh for both us actually i i don't
know what those costs are so how much
does it cost to ho like what percentage
of your revenue do you spend on or maybe
like how does the payroll compare the
payroll cost compared to like your
hosting costs
i i would say it's comparable uh hosting
costs are like even though we don't host
much of the data like we're not like
dropbox where we store files uh but the
processing the processing is quite
expensive especially if you consider
that we have uh tens of millions of free
users who are not paying us anything uh
and we're not we don't monetize them in
any way at all um
because we don't we don't sell user data
we don't show ads we don't do any of
that uh so basically all the free users
are not monetized until they subscribe
so that that makes it uh that makes us
be conscious of trusting costs
especially for regions where
not many people can
upgrade to premium like developing
countries how many employees do you have
um
i don't recall exactly but i i would say
somewhere around damn so then you're
paying a ton for those ho that
hosting
uh yeah i i would say
it could be less than period i don't
remember exactly uh but uh yeah it is
significant amount i mean that then you
supporting that many users uh and
providing a reliable service it does
what do you pay
uh it's mostly amazon crazy man
like it just runs the internet it's
crazy
well yeah we evaluate from time to time
bringing some things in-house um
and actually some things we do have
in-house not uh not necessarily like the
the hosting infrastructure but uh like
some trade model training and all that
stuff we do in-house um but uh uh so we
look into that uh so it's not like we're
just amazon and forget it uh but it is
an effective way to scale business it
doesn't affect your weight right yeah
it's just like crazy that
it's crazy it always freaks me out a
little bit that like uh we used
cloudflare and i remember one time
cloudflare went out and like our website
was
dead and so was like a quarter of the
internet
yeah
yeah it's uh it is um
this concentration it is kind of scary
um yeah it freaks me out a little bit
yeah it has its benefits but it is uh
yeah
a lot of places have a single point of
failure for significant portions of our
uh infrastructure are you uh and we'll
wrap up here in a second but um
i uh i asked you about hemingway earlier
do you do you view them as competitors
at all
not really no they they do something
that's similar and something that's
basically part of what we do and a
number of people use both products
simultaneously so we don't view them as
a competitor because they don't take
business from us uh
so yeah so it's not like who do you view
as a competitor
uh who do you use a competitor
well the biggest one is complacency just
people not realizing that they can
benefit from this i think that that's
the biggest thing that by far bigger
than any any other competitor
but other than that
once you get a certain size
everybody becomes a potential competitor
because you know when you look at big
tech companies they all
compete in some ways and all do some
things that are similar or the same so
that's that's kind of the mindset that
basically at any point anybody can
become a company yeah but are there any
i've never seen any like upstarts or any
small companies try to compete with you
guys is there a map is there many
uh there are some uh but most are
uh focusing on either a niche like a
grammarly for a specific market um
and uh i think that's that's a good way
to start and obviously we're watching
them and seeing what they're doing right
what they're doing wrong and so on um
they're there they're similar products
microsoft i think has a similar product
but again it only does part of what we
do uh so it doesn't take away much
business from us if any um so so yes and
i wouldn't i wouldn't say that there are
any kind of direct competitors at this
point um and
i'm not too worried about competition
frankly because it's just such a new
field uh that most of the market is just
untouched by anybody cool well thanks
for coming on i'm gonna uh
we're gonna wrap up now and uh i'm gonna
let you know when this is live it should
be live in like
a week i think but i appreciate you
coming on it means a lot
ah great thank you thank you so much for
having
[Music]
you